hey everybody what is going on welcome
to another tkinter with Python tutorial
for making windows and goys in this
video what we're going to be talking
about is how we can add pages so like I
was saying before this whole part I mean
this was a lot of stuff that you got
thrown at you but basically we've got a
baseline here of how we're going to
display pages and now we're going to be
talking about how we can add a bunch of
pages here and make it really easy
so as promised this will be
significantly easier than what we did
before uh we will have to change a
slight bit of code right in here
basically um to make the backend work
with multiple pages but you'll see what
I mean and then adding new pages is
really really simple so let's go ahead
and um we're going to start here in
start page so in start page um since
we're going to have multiple Pages
generally you want to allow for some
sort of navigation right from page to to
page that only makes sense um so we're
going to add a button that is going to
allow the user to go to another page so
we're going to say here um button one
and button one is going to equal tk. bu
n not 3ts just two and don't forget your
capital B there and so button one is
going to be the object that's returned
from this tkinter button um here and as
usual we pass self through it and then
we're going to pass text and text is
going to be uh visit page one okay so
this is the text that's going to go on
the button then what we're going to do
is comma and then um the other thing
that a button has is a command so you
can pass through a command and so for
example um we would have command and
command um we can say command equals and
then you can equal a function so just to
give you a really quick example here um
I'm going to make a a quick function uh
feel free to follow along as well but
we'll say Define um qf for quick
function empty parms print and then you
did
it okay so we can use that as an example
command here so we can say uh tk. button
self text equals visit page one and then
command we can say command equals uh
qf then um as usual we have to pack this
button so
um or or you could use grid but we need
to add it you know so we're going to
we're going to go ahead and use pack
because we just have a few really simple
stuff here so I'm just going to say
button one. pack right easy enough okay
so now uh when we go to run this you're
going to see that we have a slight issue
um well not this one but you'll see
eventually we'll have a slight issue so
here's our little window uh it's too
little oh goodness let me bring it back
here we go I noticed that in my videos
if I enlarge these windows as I'm
recording it makes it go crazy um if
you're prone to seizures close your eyes
for a minute but when I make it big like
this for whatever reason that makes my
video recorder really mad um anyway I've
brought it back down for you seizure
folk so now we see start page and when
they click visit page one it prints out
you did it so obviously we ran that
function but here's the kicker what if
what if we want to do uh qf and then we
want to say uh qf and then print and
then um you know
string to print is our parameter and
then we really just want to print out
whatever the string to print happens to
be so you might think to yourself well
here's what I'll do I'll do this and
then I'll do uh string to print as uh yo
well what happens here is we'll go to
run it and you see it just prints out
yoyoyo immediately and of course you
know we can hit visit page one one and
it does absolutely nothing and so that's
no bueno
so what happened here um the way that
this command works is it's going to run
this basically because you're calling
the function it's actually going to run
this function onload and then it just
it's not going to work after so there is
a slight way that we uh can get around
that using
Lambda so um so what Lambda is going to
allow us to do is is kind of like hack
our way uh Hacker Way Around this and
what Lambda is going to allow us to do
is create like a quick throwaway
function but it's only here when we call
it so it's not going to run immediately
okay so um the only major downfall here
is if that function returns something uh
and then saving that sometimes is is
problematic but also just the inherent
problem with a throwaway function um but
you'll you'll see that in a minute um
well not in a minute uh quite a few
videos probably but anyway you'll see it
eventually um so what we can do instead
is we can use Lambda though and I'm
going to I'm going to pop this down to a
new line so after this comma here I'm
just going to hit enter and then we're
going to say command equals and command
is going to equal Lambda and then you do
colon space and then uh what we could do
for example did I get R I guess I
deleted that function um let me just
show you really quick let's define qf um
pram and then we'll say print
print uh Pam so qf print Pam and then
here button TK button uh Lambda and then
you can do something like this like you
can go um
qf and then
Pam and that should allow you to get uh
get away with that there there's the
other thing that's going to be a problem
is when you go to pass like oops pass
variables through so when you're because
of what we're doing here when you if you
wanted to pass a VAR variable through or
like even do like some other complex
stuff it's just not going to work um but
you'll see what I mean in a minute oh
and we need to change pram into see this
worked like that so let's go ahead and
save and run this really quick we get
start page it didn't print anything out
and we can click this and see see this
worked so then we can you know build
this function here to actually do you
know whatever we need it to do um and
this is just a way that we can go about
doing that so
um so there's another use for
Lambda so anyway we'll delete that
function and uh and I think I'll
probably just cut the video off here and
then we'll be talking about you know
adding a new page and all of that um but
obviously this is a really integral
thing that you need to know because um
bringing another page we have to run
things through here and all that and so
that's how we can how we can run things
so anyways if you guys have any
questions or comments feel free to post
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
on subscriptions and stay tuned to the
next video